a San Diego the home of snowboarding
legends Shaun White and psionics the
makers of rocket League psionics is
currently testing the Xbox version of
the game set to release in about a month
other than that they're making more art
assets to bring players new cars
antennas and some secret stuff they
wouldn't talk about just yet
I'm here to see what they've been up to
lately you might not know this but
bionics makes more than just rocket
League this studio has been turning out
games since 2008 the year they first
released the original supersonic
acrobatic rocket powered battle cars
over the next seven years they would
grow to over 50 people strong and worked
tirelessly to find a better name for the
same game the success of rocket League
was a surprise to everyone so now they
work to add new content to the game and
come up with new ways to get players
involved so I sat down with design
director Corey Davis to talk at length
about the games release and their new
focus on community maps I would say up
until the day it came out we weren't
really sure how well it would do we
still kind of had an itching feeling on
back of our heads that it was like a
niche game and no one would really like
it was too hard so it was really like
sick flabbergasting the bleach that it
had and I think that PlayStation Plus
still really got it into a lot of
people's hands that might not have tried
it but that was really awesome just we
were just blown away depending on how
well the game did we didn't know if we
could make much DLC if we could afford
to so it's really allowed us to kind of
stretch our legs a little bit and see
like what what do we want to do for
rocket League for the release of rocket
League we really wanted to focus on like
a very good standard arena and build
around that and some of our original
fans were like you know what do you guys
do with the crazy maps from the first
game and frankly the the real limitation
is it just takes us a lot of time to
make a map to the art quality that you
see in the game rocket labs was just an
internal sort of like pet project of a
couple of us where we said what if we
made a not holodeck but kind of like
bare-bones tile set that we could just
release a bunch of maps on more quickly
and see what the community
we're gonna have three maps to start
with for the first release they're all
just completely different types of maps
than what you've seen before so there's
a throwback to the first game it's a
circular sort of donut map we're calling
a retro utopia and it's got you can
actually drive between the goals in a
tunnel and then the other two are more
focused on different ways to play rocket
League so one has very raised sides to
the map so there's a lot more
verticality than you only see and the
other one actually has a split so
there's two gold entrances and we find
that really changed up the gameplay too
we had some of our pro players saying
they wish there was more height variants
because they wanted to see what kind of
interesting aerial play you would get
when it wasn't just everyone leaping
from flat ground and that one even on
our limited testing is seen really cool
sort of like people diving down onto the
ball from above rather than just flying
up to but everything we're doing is sort
of like step by step like let's let you
guys try this out and then if everyone
likes it or if the most of you like it
then we'll push it into rank but we're
being very careful about tampering with
what we feel is sort of like the very
pure core essence of rocket League so
let's take a better look at these maps
and what you can expect first up is
utopia retro which is a throwback to the
original game but with Tron skin you can
drive through the goal to get on the
offensive or defense must also a ramp in
the middle of the doughnut it's got a
boost in it so it feels really good to
hit it in the middle of a battle
underpass is two-tiered with the second
level on the outer rim that ramps over
the goal resulting in more teamwork
based aerial hits in fact the whole
level lends itself more to high-flying
action to keep up with the elevated
sides
finally double goal is what you expected
it's a double goal with a net in between
this one is my least favorite of the
three because the extra lip in between
the goals increases your chances of your
car getting out of control you can drive
through these goals as well which will
make for some interesting team plays all
three of the maps encourage more
communication and new play tactics
you'll have to adapt your skills to meet
the needs of each map and although these
maps aren't currently in ranked
playlists they have the potential to be
added rocket labs might be a breath of
fresh air for players looking to mix up
traditional gameplay but not everyone is
interested in mutaters snowed
and my least-favorite wasteland and with
all the various match options they're
dividing their player base which can
make it harder to be matched against
someone with a similar skill level so at
the end of the day what is the core
gameplay psyonix wants their players to
experience and how does rocket labs add
to that when you play a match you win on
your skill alone and your teams go on
and not like dice rolls or you know it's
not like a MOBA where you pick your hero
poorly like it's every match it's just
sheerly how well you can manipulate your
car and your team's cars so I think
that's why we think there's room for
maps like this because it's like soccer
wouldn't change the layout of the field
sometimes the argument we see against
changing up the core playing field but
when you look at rocket League more as a
physics sport and reacting to how the
ball interacts with your environment
than we think there is the potentially
room there so that's something we want
to explore with the community you can
expect to play rocket labs in the next
February update and whether or not these
maps are up your alley at least psionics
is listening